I knew that this day was coming over
eight years ago now but now that it's
finally here it's so unreal I'm about to
click Send on a letter that will
ultimately change the course of my life
forever I'm about to quit my college
career and not because I have a million
dollars in the bank far from it but
because it's become increasingly clear
to me the kind of life that I want to
live and sometimes in order to obtain
the life that we want we have to make
tough decisions
and for me this decision means clicking
send on my resignation letter
when I was an early teenager I was
bullied because I didn't have any boys
chasing after me and I wasn't interested
in Romance
no surprise I came from a broken family
but somehow deep down I always knew even
at an early age
that my calling was to be a wife
a mother
to build a family
and to make them my priority over any
job or career I ever chose
I eventually decided to become a nurse
it's hard to believe that I've almost
spent a decade of My Life as a nurse
I have grieved the loss of certain
patients I've cried with them laughed
with them and in so many ways I feel
that my patients and their families have
given me so much more than I could ever
give to them
I have witnessed so much that cannot
ever be forgotten
being a nurse has definitely shaped me
it's taught me how to stand up for
myself with patients that are aggressive
it's taught me to Value life and family
and it's helped me improve my confidence
I went from a shy insecure 21 year old
to a confident ICU nurse that adored to
make her patients feel truly seen and
cared for I currently work in hospice
nursing where the entire focus of my job
is to help dying patients have the best
quality of life possible while also
providing resources for their families
I'm incredibly proud that the agency I
work for provides free counseling for
families even a year after experiencing
a loss free summer camps for children
who have lost a loved one
remembrance ceremonies and so much more
as a 20-something year old who often
felt like nothing bad could ever happen
to her
hospice nursing has helped show me the
value of life because I'm presented with
the idea of death every day you may
think it's depressing but I've never
seen it that way it reminds me how small
I am in this huge world and yet shocks
me how blessed I am to have all the
things that I have in the life that I
have despite my weaknesses and my
failures
which are quite abundant
sure there are some aspects of my job
that I don't like mainly the office
stuff
but isn't that the case with anything in
life
nothing is ever truly perfect
I love what I do
but yet I knew the day was coming when I
would quit nursing long before I even
had children long before I even got
married at the age of 17 I intentionally
decided on a four-year career and was
closed to the idea of anything beyond
that because I knew that nursing was my
service to the world
but having a family was my calling Rudy
always knew that I wanted to homeschool
and so to make that happen we worked
overtime almost every single week before
our first child was born
and even months after
and we built our first home as her own
General Contractors no garage no
basement just 1200 square feet of love
and coziness
a freedom from rent and a mortgage
for the last three years I have worked
full time waking up at 5am on most days
to spend time with my kids before I go
to work
continue to serve at my church and
meticulously planning my schedules to
continue to post videos for this YouTube
channel
but the time has come to close a chapter
in my life to start a new one
Anna will start school this year and I
have always longed to homeschool
for me there's no other option
my co-workers tell me Well if it doesn't
work out for you financially you can
always come back and while having a plan
Z is nice it's a plan Z for a reason
because you see when you truly want
something
there should be no other choice but to
go for it to take the leap
to take those small steps and know you
tried
I'm not telling you to quit your job but
if you're working in a job that you hate
or you feel stuck in life take the time
to ask yourself what your values are and
what you would love to do if money were
no objective and take small steps to
getting there don't just wish for it to
happen even Tiny Steps are progress
for US Financial minimalism and getting
out of debt had a deadline Rudy's income
from his construction job is anything
but stable he has no paid days off and I
still don't know what we're going to do
about health insurance I don't have it
all figured out but I do know one thing
we will all die at some point
it's inevitable for me this knowing
motivates me to value my time
to make it count
to do the things I fear
to go with the seasons of my life
and just allow myself to be
if there's anything that I've learned
from my patients it's that it's better
to die having failed at something with
the Peace of knowing you tried than to
die with the regret of never having
tried it all homeschooling was always an
absolute for me it was never up for
debate and thankfully Rudy is supportive
of this and he's also supportive of my
creative dreams which are many and some
of them are quite big
my co-workers are right I could
homeschool and take care of the home and
work part-time if God forbid Rudy
couldn't work or construction slows
which sometimes it does
but I would lose something precious to
me this YouTube channel
I think that creativity is not only
something nice to do if you get the
chance
but it's something that brings joy to
our lives
and when we feel Joy we're also able to
give more of ourselves to others
this is something that is important to
me it is something I value
and I can't lose that only out of fear
or because I want to stay stuck in my
comfort zone
change is scary the unknown the
uncertainty is scary
that's okay just take that first step
write that first sentence of that book
you dream about publishing
start posting a few things for sale to
help you pay off your debts or apply for
your dream job
wherever your life takes you remember
your values and don't die with regret
thank you guys for watching this video
if you liked it please give it a thumbs
up and help support my channel and if
you'd like to see more on minimalism and
slow living don't forget to subscribe so
that you won't miss when I post a new
video
I'll see you in the next one bye for now